THIRTY WILL CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA ATKINS BATES BAKER
FORTUS BRADFORD CABALLERO
CORTESE DALLY DODD THE RUSSELL
EGGMAN GLAZER GONZALEZGROVE
HERTZBERG WEST SO- TADO JONES
KAMLAGER LAYERED LEYVA LIMÓN
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MEN NEWMAN
NIELSEN A CHOI BOGUE PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN AMBERG BY CAL SKI WIENER
WELL. QUORUM IS PRESENT. AT AB
MEMBERS WITH MEMBERS OR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY CENTER
GONZALEZ. HE'S REMAIN STANDING
WILL BE LED THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY CENTER
NEWMAN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
GOD WHO CREATED US VERY GOOD
EVERY DAY IS A DAY TO CELEBRATE
THE SPLENDOR THE WONDER OF ALL
WOMEN. FOR ALL THAT WE KERRY
WATER ON OUR HEADS BABIES IN OUR
ROOMS THE LEGACY OF OUR
ANCESTORS DREAMS FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS. WE ASK FOR STRENGTH
IN OUR BONES AND LOVE FOR FRAMES
. FOR ALL THAT WE RAISE THE
CHILDREN OF OUR VILLAGES
COMMUNITIES OF RESILIENCE
RESISTANT HANDS DEFIANT VOICES.
WE ASK FOR THE COURAGE TO KEEP
ASSERTING IN A WORLD THAT HONORS
ARE BEING. FOR ALL THAT WE BEAR
VIOLENCE BOTH PHYSICAL AND
EMOTIONAL INJUSTICES BOTH KNOWN
AND UNKNOWN THE INESCAPABLE WAY
TO MISOGYNY THE TRAUMA OF
GENERATIONS WE ASK FOR AN END TO
THE FORCES THAT TERROR. AND THE
FORCE OF LOVE TO REPAIR. FOR ALL
THAT WE ARE RESILIENT POWERFUL
LOVING HOSPITABLE CREATIVE
DARING BEAUTIFUL VALUABLE
GENEROUS WE ASK FOR FULLNESS OF
JOY AND GLADNESS IN OUR
EXISTENCE. GRANT WOMEN AROUND
THE WORLD REMINDERS THIS DAY AND
EVERY DAY OF OUR IMMEASURABLE
WORTH AND YOUR DIVINE IMAGE
WITHIN US ALMOND. WHEN A C. DS
MAKE A LEGACY ON THE CESAR
CHAVEZ DAY PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE.
MEMBERS OKAY. MEMBERS WITHOUT
OBJECTION WILL MOVE TO FILE IN
FIFTEEN ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE
SEVENTY NINE OTHERS RESOLUTION
AT THE DESK INVOKING ARTICLE
FOUR SECTION EIGHTY OF THE
CONSTITUTION THAT THIS REQUEST
HAS BEEN APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE READ
THE RESOLUTION. RESOLVED AT THAT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE PRESENTS A CASE EMERGENCY
THAT. URGENCY AS THAT TERM IS
USED IN ARTICLE FOUR SECTION
EIGHTY OF THE CONSTITUTION AND
THE PROVISION OF THAT SECTION
REQUIRING THAT THE BILL BE READ
ON THREE SEVERAL DAYS. IN EACH
HOUSE IS HEREBY DISPENSED WITH
AND IT IS ORDERED THAT SAID BILL
BE READ THE SECOND AND THIRD
TIMES AND PLACED UPON ITS
PASSAGE. RESOLUTION RENT. THANK
YOU MEMBERS- IF YOU PLEASE
KINDLY TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFFER FOR WILL APPRECIATE IT A
SECRETARY A CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN. HI ARCHULETA
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES NO BACKER.
BYE I FOR JUST. BRADFORD I HAVE
ITEM I FOR TAXIS I DALY NOPE
DODD. I TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ I GROWTH. NO
HERTZBERG AYE WESSEL AYE FURTADO
AYE JONES. KAMLAGER I LAYERED
AYE LEYVA I LIMON I MCGUIRE I
MELENDEZ NO MAN I NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN. TOTAL OF BOTH. PAN. I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO I
SKINNER I STERN AYE NUMBER I WAS
ASKING I WIENER I WELL. MEMBERS
THAT WE'VE BEEN ASKED TO RESTART
KILEY STOPPER CONVERSATIONS WERE
TAKING CONVERSATIONS OFF THE
FLOOR AND WE REALLY NEED
EVERYONE'S ATTENTION FOR THIS
MEASURE THAT MA'AM CIRCULAR KEY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORCHES JONES. NIELSEN NO BUT
CHAO ABOUT. WILK. THE EYES ARE
THIRTY ONE KNOWS ARE FIVE THE
CONSTITUTION IS DISPENSED WITH A
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ THE
BILL A SECOND AND THIRD TIME.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON
AN ACT RELATING TO TENANCY AND
DECLARE THE URGENCY THERE AT
STAKE FOR TO ME DAILY. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AN ACT
RELATING TO TENANCY AND
ACQUIRING THE URGENCY THERE OF
SIX IMMEDIATELY. THE NUMBER YOU
MAY PROCEED- THANK YOU OF MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS- PLEASE
PRESENT AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY
NINE WHICH WILL EXTEND EVICTION
PROTECTIONS FOR TENANTS WHO
FILED FOR EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE BY THE END OF THIS
MONTH MEANING BY MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT. SINCE THE RENT RELIEF
PROGRAM LAUNCHED A YEAR AGO
CALIFORNIA'S LED THE NATION
DELIVERING ASSISTANCE TO THOSE
MOST IN NEED AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR HOUSING. THE STATE
PROGRAMS DELIVERED OVER TWO
POINT FOUR SIX BILLION DOLLARS
DIRECT ASSISTANCE TO DATE
HELPING MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
FOURTEEN THOUSAND LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS. THEY OFF THE RENTAL
DEBT AND AVOID EVICTION. ONE IN
THREE PAYMENTS NATIONALLY BEEN
MADE IN CALIFORNIA TO TENANTS
AND LANDLORDS AND NEED BUT IT'S
TAKING LONGER THAN EXPECTED FOR
THE STATE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS FOR QUOTED NINETEEN
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE.
THOUSANDS CONTINUE TO WAIT FOR
RELIEF FOR OTHER APPLICATIONS
ARE PENDING. IT WOULD BE CRUEL
WASTEFUL AND UNFAIR TO SUBJECT
CALIFORNIANS TO FICTION THE LOSS
OF RENTAL INCOME NOW WHEN
THEY'VE DONE EVERYTHING ASKED OF
THEM BY FILING AND COMPLETING
THEIR APPLICATION. DISTRIBUTION
OF THEIR EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE IS IMMINENT AB TWENTY
ONE SEVENTY NINE WILL EXTEND
VIXEN PROTECTIONS THROUGH JUNE
THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY TWO FOR
CALIFORNIANS OF FILED A
COMPLETELY CATION AGAIN BY
MIDNIGHT TONIGHT. THE BILL
JOINED BY PRESIDENT SUPPORT IN
THE ASSEMBLY PASSED THE ASSEMBLY
SIXTY TWO TO ONE AND- PART
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE- WHICH PROVED THE BILL
A BIPARTISAN FASHION EVEN AS
CALIFORNIA RETURNS TO PRE
PANDEMIC LIFE EMERGENCY RENTAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM COMES TO AN
END. AB TWENTY ONE SEVENTY NINE
WILL HELP MAXIMIZE EVERY LAST
EMERGENCY RENTAL ASSISTANCE
DOLLAR HE PEOPLE IN THEIR HOMES.
AYE ORIGIN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU A
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE CENTER
WIENER. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MISTER PRESIDENT- I- HI THIS IS
A TOUGH ONE BECAUSE THIS BILL IS
A SOPHIE'S CHOICE IN MANY WAYS
AND I APPRECIATE THE WORK THAT
OUR LEADERSHIP AND LEADERSHIP OF
THE ASSEMBLY AND THE AUTHORS OF
THE BILL HAVE DONE ON THIS- AND
THIS BILL WILL OBVIOUSLY IS A
VERY IMPORTANT AND HELPING THE
PROXIMATE LI HUNDRED TWENTY
THOUSAND CALIFORNIANS WHO HAVE
ALREADY APPLIED FOR RENT RELIEF-
BUT HAS NOT HAVE NOT RECEIVED
EVER REALLY FOR WILL GIVE THEM
AN ADDITIONAL THREE MONTHS. OF
STATE ELECTION PROTECTION AND
THAT IS VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND
I FULLY SUPPORT THAT PORTION OF
THIS BILL- BUT I WANT TO EXPLAIN
INCLUDING MY OWN CONSTITUENTS
WHY I WILL NOT BE SUPPORTING-
THIS BILL- TODAY- IT DOES HAVE A
VERY IMPORTANT WORK PROTECTING
THOSE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE WHO WERE IN THE QUEUE ON
HOWEVER THE BILL THAT CLOSES THE
APPLICATION PROCESS AT MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT ANYONE WHO IS NOT
APPLIED- BY TONIGHT WILL NO
LONGER BE ABLE TO APPLY ND
BUSCA THOSE STATE PROTECTIONS.
THE STATE ELECTION PROTECTIONS
FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
NOT APPLIED BY MIDNIGHT TONIGHT
WILL GO AWAY AT MIDNIGHT TONIGHT
AND THEY WILL HAVE NO FURTHER
STATE EVICTION PROTECTIONS
RELATING TO CODE- AND THEN IN
ADDITION SOME CITIES BUT NOT
OTHERS WILL NOT HAVE THE ABILITY
WILL BE OVER RIDDEN AND THEIR
ABILITY TO ENFORCE LOCAL
EVICTION PROTECTIONS SO FOR
ANYONE WHO FOR WHATEVER REASON
LANGUAGE ACCESS ANYTHING ELSE IS
NOT APPLIED FOR STATE RUN RELIEF
BY TONIGHT. THEY WILL NOT BE
ABLE O APPLY THEY WILL DO STATE
EVICTION PROTECTIONS AND IF YOU
LIVE IN A PLACE LIKE SAN
FRANCISCO YOU WILL LOSE YOUR
LOCAL YOU ARE NOT OF ANY LOCAL
COVERT RELATED ADDICTION
PROTECTIONS SOME CITIES OAKLAND
CITY OF LA ALAMEDA ARE ABLE WILL
BE ABLE TO ENFORCE THE LOCAL-
EVICTION PROTECTIONS. BUT PLACES
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO ONE NOT BE. I
AM NOT IS BECAUSE WHEN WE PASS
YOUR- EVICTION MORE. IN ALL
TWENTY TWENTY WE GRANDFATHERED
IN THE PRE AUGUST NINETEEN
TWENTY TWENTY OF EXIT LOCAL
EVICTION PROTECTIONS BUT
PREEMPTED ANYTHING MOVING
FORWARD. THAT MADE SENSE THAT.
THAT WAS PART OF A DEAL SAYING
WE'RE GONNA HAVE STATEWIDE.
ELECTION PROTECTIONS BUT WE'RE
GOING TO PREEMPT ANY NEW LOCAL
PROTECTIONS WAS A COMPROMISE AND
I SUPPORTED BY. THAT CUT OFF OF
AUGUST NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY
DOES NOT MAKE SENSE TODAY WE
SHOULD NOT BE PREEMPTING PLACES
LIKE SAN FRANCISCO- FROM
STEPPING IN TO SAY WERE LOSING
STATE PROTECTIONS. WE WANNA
LOCALLY PROTECT OUR RENTERS I
REPRESENT A COMMUNITY THAT IS
62% RENTERS A LOT OF PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE. FROM THE
PANDEMIC FOR DOING BETTER HEALTH
WISE BUT THE ECONOMIC DAMAGE
OCCUR BECAUSE INFLICTED ON MANY
PARTICULAR LOW INCOME FAMILIES
CONTINUES THAT IS NOT OVER. AND
WE SHOULD NOT BE STOPPING CITIES
FROM STEPPING ON TO PROTECT
RUNNERS WHO HAVE BEEN HARMED. BY
CODE SO I RESPECT. THE WORK THAT
WENT INTO THIS BILL- I
UNDERSTANDS WHY OTHERS ARE
SUPPORTING US BECAUSE THERE ARE
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY THOUSAND
PEOPLE. WHO ARE IN THE QUEUE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
PROTECTIONS AFTER MIDNIGHT
TONIGHT I'M NOT CRITICIZING- MY
COLLEAGUES FOR SUPPORTING US BUT
EXPLAINING WHY I WILL NOT BE
ABLE. TO SUPPORT- THIS BILL
TODAY I IN TERMS OF MY SUPPORT
FOR MY OWN- CONSTITUENTS MANY OF
WHOM ARE. STILL STRUGGLING FROM
THE PANDEMIC THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. C.
NINE SEVEN FIFTEEN ROUND- THANK
YOU IN RETURN BUT THERE IS ARTS
CENTER ALLEN A LAST MINUTE REYES
ATTENDED YEAH- I WANTED I WANTED
MYSELF WITH WITH THAT SO MANY OF
THE COMMENTS MADE BY OUR OUR
FRIEND FROM SERVICES GO I WILL
BE SUPPORTING IT BECAUSE I THINK
IN THE END OF THE DAY THIS IS
GOING TO PROVIDE NEEDED RELIEF
TO SO MANY CALIFORNIANS BUT
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT MANY
PEOPLE ARE BEING LEFT BEHIND- IN
THIS LEGISLATION. OUT WE ALL
KNOW THAT MEMBERS- WE'RE
SUPPORTING THIS EVEN THOUGH WE
KNOW- THIS IS NOT COMPLETE
LEGISLATION BECAUSE WE KNOW IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR THOSE WHO WE
HELPED OUT BUT I REALLY DO HOPE
THAT WE TAKE AN OPPORTUNITY TO-
TO LOOK AT THE ISSUES THE FOLKS
THAT ARE LEFT BEHIND L. A.
COUNTY SAN FRANCISCO AND
ELSEWHERE AND THAT WE BOTH TRY
TO ADDRESS THAT CHALLENGE- AND
ALSO THE CHALLENGE OF. COUNSEL
AND OTHER SORTS OF SUPPORTS I TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT THE-
THE FOLKS ARE GOING TO BE LEFT
BEHIND SO I'LL BE SUPPORTING A
RELUCTANTLY TODAY- BUT THERE A
LOT OF UNFINISHED ISSUES ON THE
TABLE HERE MEMBERS. I THANK YOU
. MR ROBERT YOU CAN OCCUR. THANK
IS PRESENT- THIS THIS BILL IS A
COMPROMISE. THUS EVERYTHING THAT
EVERYONE WANTED IS NOT HERE-
THERE ARE STILL CALIFORNIANS
THAT ARE SUFFERING IF WE DON'T
PASS THIS BILL. WILL BE A GREAT
NUMBER OF CALIFORNIANS WHO WILL.
NOT BE ABLE TO AVAIL THEMSELVES
OF BOTH PROTECTIONS IN THE
RELIEF- AND- THERE IS THERE IS
CONTINUING WORK TO BE DONE. WITH
THEM BUT NOW WE PASS THIS BILL-
I'M GRATEFUL TO LEADERSHIP AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAYSON WICK-
WICKS FOR ALL THE HARD WORK.
THEY PUT INTO THIS COMPROMISE
AND I URGE AND I VOTE. M.
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES. BAKER I FOR JUST AYE
BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO AYE
PROTESTING AYE DALY. I DODD FIVE
ZERO AYE EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH I HERTZBERG
AYE WESSEL. HI HER TADO I JONES
I KAMLAGER FIVE LAYERED I LEYVA
AYE LIMÓN. I MCGUIRE AYE
MELENDEZ. MAN AYE NEWMAN AYE
NIELSEN AYE A TO A VOTE. I PAN I
PORTANTINO AYE ROTH AYE RUBIO I
SKINNER. FIVE STERN HI NUMBER
ALL RIGHT HI MY COUNTY I WIENER
NO WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. BATES MELENDEZ. WILK.
THE EYES ARE THIRTY SIX TO ONE
ON THE URGENCY DE ICER THIRTY
SIX TO ONE ON THE MEASURE OF THE
MEASURE PASSES. BUT WE'RE NOW
MOVING ON TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS- OVER
THIRTY YEARS AGO A YOUNG HIGH
SCHOOL GRADUATES STARTED WORKING
AS A TOUR GUIDE HERE IN THE
CAPITAL. SHE GOT MARRIED
GRADUATED FROM SACRAMENTO STATE.
BOUGHT A HOUSE HAD TWO CHILDREN
AND NOW HAS THREE GRANDCHILDREN
ALL WHILE WORKING FOR THE SENATE
STATE PARKS AND THE PEOPLE OF
CALIFORNIA. I'VE GOTTEN TO KNOW
HER OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS
BECAUSE HER SHE'S MARRIED TO MY
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR. IF YOU
KNOW HER YOU KNOW HER SMILE AND
HER PERSONALITY THAT LIGHTS UP A
ROOM TODAY I WANT TO
CONGRATULATE MANY OROZCO ON HER
RETIREMENT. AND FOR HER SERVICE
TO THE GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU MINDY AND THIS GRAND
BUILDING AND THOSE OF US STILL
HERE. WE'LL MISS YOU.
MEMBERS THE MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGE FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ. WHAT'S COMMITTEE
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. THAT MOVING
ON OTHER ANY MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS
AND NOTICES. C. NINE WE MOVE ON
TO CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE STARTING WITH SECOND
READING FILE A FILE ITEMS THE
ONE FOURTEEN SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. SENATE BILL TWELVE OH TWO
WITH AMENDMENTS SENATE BILL.
836-928-9359. THIRTY SEVEN NINE
FIFTY SIX TEN OH FIVE SENATE
BILL NINE FORTY WITH AMENDMENTS.
SENATE BILL TEN NINETY SIX WITH
AMENDMENTS TEN FIFTY FOUR WITH
AMENDMENTS NINE OF SEVEN WITH
AMENDMENTS EIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
WITH AMENDMENTS TWELVE NINETY
NINE WITH AMENDMENTS. SENATE
BILL THIRTEEN NINETY FOUR AND-
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE. THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY MEMBERS
WE'RE NOW GOING TO MOVE TO
UNFINISHED BUSINESS FILE ITEM
SEVENTEEN CENTER BAKER PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL FIVE OH FOUR BY SENATOR
BACK FOR AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTIONS IN DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO AFFECT
MEALING CENTER BETTER. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON SORRY GOOD
MORNING FATHER FOR CONTINUE TO
BE A BI PARTISAN VOTER
REGISTRATION MEASURE SPONSORED
BY OUR STATE CLERKS ELECTION
OFFICIALS IS BACK FOR
CONCURRENCE AFTER ASSEMBLY
AMENDMENTS. THE SECULAR STATE
REQUESTED URGENT AMENDMENTS TO
BE TAKEN THE ASSEMBLY DOES TWO
THINGS TO. RELATE TO VOTE BY
MAIL CLEAN UP TO THE HISTORIC
PASSAGE OF SB THIRTY SEVEN WHICH
MAKE CALIFORNIA LATEST TO
PERMANENTLY MALE 1100% OF
REGISTERED VOTERS A BALLOT. THE
FIRST CHANGE WAS A QUESTION FOR
THE VOTER REGISTRATION CARD
APPLICATION. AT THE SECOND. I
BELIEVE THE RUMORS REQUIREMENT
THAT REQUIRES THE COUNTY
ELECTION OFFICIAL TO MAIL AN
APPLICATION TO BE A VOTE BY MAIL
VOTER. AGAIN THIS IS NOT NEEDED
SINCE ALL CALIFORNIA'S SERVERS
ARE NOW VOTE BY MAIL AND RECEIVE
A BALLOT DO NOT NEED TO APPLY
THE CHANGE URGENT AT THE JUNE
PRIMARY AND ONLY SAVER
CHARACTERS OF MONEY AND TIME.
THAT WILL REDUCE VOTER CONFUSION
. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER BACK. MEMBERS
QUESTIONS. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
. SEEING AND HEARING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS
AYE BATES AYE BECKER AYE PORCHES
AYE BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM. HI
CORTESE AYE DALY I DODD I TO
RAZA I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER I
GONZALEZ I GROWTH AYE HERTZBERG
I WAS SO. I FURTADO I JONES I
KAMLAGER. FIVE PLAYERS I LEYVA
AYE MON AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ
AYE MIN AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN I
PATROL BOAT I PAN AYE PORTANTINO
. HI RALPH I RUBIO I SKINNER I
STERN AYE NUMBER I BY CAL SKI
AYE WIENER AYE WILK. FIVE THIRTY
NINE NO ZERO ON THE URGENCY OF
THREE NINE NINE ZERO THE
ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
CONCURRED IN.
MEMBERS MOVING TO SENATE THIRD
READING A FILE ITEM TWENTY TWO
CEREMONY PREPARED. BENZER DAY
PLEASE READ SENATE RESOLUTION
SEVENTY ONE BY SENATOR LIMÓN
RELATIVE TO SAYS A SHOP AS DAY.
THANK YOU COLLEAGUES. TODAY I AM
PROUD TO PRESENT SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY ONE WHICH
RECOGNISES TODAY MARCH THIRTY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SECOND AS
THE DATE OF PUBLIC SERVICE IN
HONOR OF THE BIRTH AND LEGACY OF
CIVIL RIGHTS LEADER AND LABOR
ACTIVIST SAYS THAT TRAVIS.
CHAVEZ WAS BORN IN YUMA ARIZONA
ON MARCH THIRTY FIRST NINETEEN
TWENTY SEVEN EARLY IN HIS
CHILDHOOD DURING THE GREAT
DEPRESSION HIS FAMILY LOST THEIR
HOME AND FARM. THEY JOINED
THIRTY THOUSAND OTHERS WHO MOVED
TO CALIFORNIA FOR FARM WORK.
THESE WORKERS LIVED IN TENTS
MAKESHIFT HOUSING THAT OFTEN
LOCKED THE BATHROOM ELECTRICITY
OR RUNNING WATER. AFTER
COMPLETING EIGHTH GRADE HE
DROPPED OUT TO WORK FULL TIME
WITH HIS FAMILY IN THE FIELDS.
LATER IN NINETEEN FORTY SIX HE
JOINED THE U. S. NAVY FOR TWO
YEARS THEN SETTLED IN EAST SAN
JOSE BARIO NAMED SIZE STEEP
WITNESS GET OUT IF YOU CAN. TO
RAISE THE FAMILY WITH EIGHT
CHILDREN. WITH FRED ROSS AN
ORGANIZER FOR THE COMMUNITY
SERVICE ORGANIZATION HE
ESTABLISHED COMMUNITY SERVICE
ORGANIZATION CHAPTERS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND ARIZONA DURING
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES. THROUGH
HIS WORK HE HELPED LATINOS
REGISTER TO VOTE AND PUSH FOR
BASIC PUBLIC SERVICES AND
INFRASTRUCTURE IN VARIOUS. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY TWO AFTER THE
COMMUNITY SERVICE ORGANIZATION
WOULD NOT LET HIM ORGANIZE FARM
WORKERS HE USED HIS LIFE SAVINGS
TO BUILD THE NATIONAL FARM
WORKERS ASSOCIATION WITH HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS. THE NEW
FIRSTHAND THE STRUGGLE OF
FARMWORKERS. HIS WORK TO
ORGANIZE AND UNIONIZE LIFTED HIS
COMMUNITY. IN NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE HE ORGANIZED A MAJOR STRIKE
WITH THE FILIPINO AMERICAN
FARMWORKERS GAINST GRAPE
GROWERS IN CALIFORNIA. DEDICATED
TO LACK AUSA BUT BECAUSE HIS
EFFORTS LED TO HISTORIC
AGRICULTURE LABOR RELATIONS ACT
OF NINETEEN SEVENTY FIVE IN
CALIFORNIA. THIS IS THE FIRST
AND STILL THE ONLY LAW IN THE
NATION TO ENCOURAGE AND PROTECT
THE RIGHTS OF FARMWORKERS TO
ORGANIZE AND BARGAIN WITH THEIR
EMPLOYEES. THROUGH COUNTLESS
STRIKES BOYCOTTS MARCHES AND
FASS SAYS THAT CHÁVEZ
SUCCESSFULLY INCREASED PUBLIC
AWARENESS OF FARMWORKER
CONDITIONS. BUT THESE ARE NOT
JUST STRUGGLES OF THE PAST.
TODAY THE PEOPLE WHO LABOR TO
PUT FOOD ON OUR TABLES STILL GO
HUNGRY. WORKERS DEEMED AS
ESSENTIAL DURING A PANDEMIC
THEY'LL FACE CHALLENGES SUCH AS
INADEQUATE ENFORCEMENT OF
PESTICIDE SAFETY LEVER
PROTECTION LAWS IN THE FIELDS
THEY STILL FACE LOW WAGES A LACK
OF ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE AND AN
ADVOCATE HOUSING AND
DISCRIMINATION. WE MUST CONTINUE
TO LOOK AFTER AN ADVOCATE FOR
ALL OF OUR MARGINALIZED
COMMUNITIES. TODAY AND EVERY DAY
LET'S UP HOLD AN HONOR THE
LEGACY OF THE GREAT CESA CHAVEZ.
AND LIKE AUSA. THANK YOU I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU MEMBERS ANY
DISCUSSION DEBATE AT CENTER PAN
. THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT
SENATOR SUNDAY HALF OF THE ASIAN
AMERICAN AND PACIFIC ISLANDER
LET'S THEY'VE CAUCUS I TO BUY AN
HONOR TO RISE A SPORT SR SEVENTY
ONE WHICH RECOGNIZES THESE ARE
SOME OF HIS DAY AND I THINK MY
GOOD FRIEND FROM SANTA BARBARA
FOR GREENS FOR. CALIFORNIA
UNITED FARM WORKERS MOVEMENT HAS
ALWAYS BEEN A PARTNERSHIP
BETWEEN ASIAN AMERICANS AND
LATINO. AMERICAN COMMUNITIES. IN
NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE LARRY IT
ALONG ALONG WITH PHILIP. PHILIP
VERACRUZ PETER VELASCO. IF YOU
BONTA AND MANY OTHER FILIPINO
FARMWORKERS INITIATED THE DELANO
GRAPE STRIKE. EITHER CHAVOUS
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
UNITING TO FIGHT FOR ONE'S
RIGHTS AND LEAD MEXICAN FARM
WORKERS TO WALK. SHIPPED IF THE
SCALES IN FAVOR OF THE LABOR
MOVEMENT. CESAR CHAVEZ DAY
REMINDS US THAT WE ARE STRONGER
WHEN WE STAND TOGETHER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON SR SEVENTY ONE THANK YOU.
SENATOR RAZA. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. AS CHAIR OF THE LATINO
CAUCUS IT IS MY HONOR TO RISE
TODAY IN STRONG SUPPORT OF A
STAR SEVENTY THREE. SAYS THAT
CHAVEZ'S LIFE SERVES AS AN
EXTRAORDINARY EXAMPLE OF HOW ONE
PERSON CAN HAVE A HUGE IMPACT ON
ALL OF OUR LIVES ON A PERSONAL
NOTE SAYS ARE CHÁVEZ CHANGED MY
LIFE. MY FAMILY WERE FARMWORKERS
WHEN HE STARTED HIS MOVEMENT I
REMEMBER STARTING OUT AS A KID
WORKING FROM PICKING COTTON TO
PICKING GRAPES SLEEPING WITH A
PILE OF SIBLINGS UNDER THE STARS
IN THE BACK OF MY DAD'S FLAT BED
TRUCK WE HAD NOWHERE ELSE TO
SLEEP MANY TIMES. THAT WAS OUR
VERSION OF TODAY'S TRAILER HOME
. A BIG PART OF SAYS SARS LEGACY
OFTEN OVERLOOKED WAS HIS CORE
COMMITMENT TO AND BELIEF IN
NONVIOLENCE. YOU PEOPLE REMEMBER
THAT SAYS SIZE FIRST FAST AND
THE LIONEL WAS AGAINST THE
VIOLENCE THAT HAD BEGUN TO
SPREAD DURING THE DELANO GRAPE
STRIKE. HE WOULD HAVE NO PART IN
THE VIOLENCE HIS RESPONSE WAS A
FAST. THIS IS COMMITMENT TO
NONVIOLENCE IS AS RELEVANT TODAY
AS IT WAS THEN. FROM THE MURDER
OF A MOD ARMORY WALLY JOGGED IN
GEORGIA THE MURDER OF GEORGE
FLOYD IN MINNESOTA. FROM THE
BOMBING OF A MATERNITY HOSPITAL
IN UKRAINE TO THE STAGE AT THE
OSCARS. FROM THE KILLINGS AT AN
LGBTQ NIGHTCLUB IN FLORIDA TO
THE OUTBREAK OF VIOLENCE VIOLENT
HATE CRIMES AGAINST ASIAN
AMERICANS. FROM THE DEATHS
DURING THE JANUARY SIXTH ATTACK
ON OUR NATION'S CAPITAL. TO ONE
OF THIS CAPITAL'S LONG TERM
LOBBYIST BEING MURDERED IN HER
HOME. THIS IS COMMITMENT TO
NONVIOLENCE IS BEST HONORED IF
WE ALL PAUSE NOW IN A MOMENT OF
SILENCE. COLLEAGUES ON BEHALF OF
THE LATINO CAUCUS I EXTEND OUR
THANKS AND APPRECIATION TO THE
AUTHOR FOR HER LEADERSHIP FOR
WORK ON THIS IMPORTANT
RESOLUTION AND I ASK ALL MEMBERS
JOIN IN SUPPORTING SR. SEVENTY
THREE GIVE ME A SENSE OF CHAVEZ
. THANK YOU. CENTER CHIRLA.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. I RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT SR SEVENTY ONE
I THANK MY COLLEAGUES FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. IN
RECOGNITION OF CESAR CHAVEZ DAY.
TO HONOR THIS VETERAN. I STAND
AS THE CHAIR OF MILITARY AND
VETERANS COMMITTEE FITTER CHÁVEZ
ONE OF THE NATION'S GREATEST
CHAMPIONS FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE. IT
IS LIFE FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
THE UNDER SERVED IN THE UNDER
REPRESENTED FOR DECADES
FOLLOWING HIS HONORABLE
DISCHARGE FROM THE UNITED STATES
NAVY. AND I WILL INFORM YOU ALL
THAT THE UNITED STATES NAVY HAS
A SHIP IN HIS NAME IN HIS HONOR
. THE OTHER LOS CAESARS TRAVIS
CELEBRATED ANNUALLY. ON HIS
BIRTHDAY MARCH THIRTY FIRST
RECOGNIZE YOUR HEATER CHAVEZ NOT
ONLY FOR HIS ADVOCACY IN SUPPORT
OF FARMWORKERS IT CELEBRATES THE
LABOR MOVEMENT AND ALL THOSE WHO
HAVE ADVOCATED THROUGHOUT THE
STATE. FOR YEARS UPON YEARS FOR
WORKING CONDITIONS BETTER
WORKING CONDITIONS AND HIGHER
WAGES FOR THOSE WORKING ON OUR
FARMS. IT HAS BEEN CELEBRATED IN
CALIFORNIA HIS NINETEEN NINETY
FIVE AND ACROSS MANY STAGE FOR
DECADES SINCE UNITED FARM
WORKERS UNION. WAS FIRST
ESTABLISHED IN THE. NINETEEN
SIXTY TO FIGHT FOR FARMWORKERS
IN THE FIELD. HE'S OUR CHAVEZ
GAVE US GAVE US IN HIS WORKERS
HOPE. WHAT THE GROWER DID KNOW
HE SAID IS THAT IT'S NOT THE
BANANAS ARE GREAT FOR THE
LETTERS IT'S THE PEOPLE THE
PEOPLE. IT'S THE PEOPLE. HE
OFTEN REMINDED US THAT ALL OF US
ARE GOD'S CHILDREN. EVERY SHOT
EVERY SINGLE ONE OF US SHOULD
VALUE LIFE. HE WAS PROUD OF THE
PEOPLE HE FOUGHT FOR. AND WHO HE
WAS THIS IS WHY HIS MOVEMENT.
INTERPRETED TODAY REINTERPRETED
THE MEANING. THAT EVERYONE
SHOULD BE TREATED WITH PRIDE
WITH HONOR AND DIGNITY NO MATTER
WHAT THE JOB IS NO MATTER WHERE
HE OR SHE LIVES OR WEYRICH HERE
SHE COMES FROM. AND THAT IS WHY.
WHEN WE HEAR SEE SUPPORT THIS
AND IT IS SAID IT RALLIES AND WE
HEAR IT OFTEN WE ARE NEAR THE
CAPITAL. HE SUPPORT THIS. ACTION
WITHIN THE COMMUNITIES ACTION
WITH WITHIN US TO TREAT PEOPLE
WITH DIGNITY AND PRIDE TO WORK
TOGETHER. FOR THESE REASONS AND
MANY MORE IT IS AN HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE AND CELEBRATE SHE'S
ARE CHAVEZ DAY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. AND WE SHOULD
CELEBRATED ACROSS THIS NATION
AND FOR THESE REASONS I THANK
YOU AND URGE AND I BOTH. THE
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. SIR
CABALLERO THAN CENTER BRADFORD
THIS AND RUBIO. IS OUR COPIER.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I RISE ON
BEHALF OF THE OF THE LEGISLATIVE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTY ONE. INJUSTICES THE CESA
CHAVEZ FOUGHT AGAINST WERE DE
HUMANIZING DANGEROUS AND IN SOME
CASES DEADLY. THAT'S HER CHAVEZ
IN UNION WORKERS WHO MARCHED
WITH THEM FACE DISCRIMINATION
AND VIOLENCE WHEN THEY SOUGHT
FAIR TREATMENT AND UNION
PROTECTIONS. THESE THREATS WERE
COMPOUNDED FOR THE WOMEN WHO
STAYED WITH HIM IN THE FACE OF
OPPRESSION. AS IT SAID GINGER
ROGERS DID EVERYTHING FRED
ASTAIRE DID ONLY BACKWARDS AND
IN HEELS WOMEN'S INVOLVEMENT IN
THE FARMWORKERS MOVEMENT WENT
BEYOND WHAT WE SEE IN TEXTBOOKS
THEY WERE A DRIVING FORCE
HELPING TO ORGANIZE. PICKET AND
PERFORM FIELDWORK AND THEY TOOK
ON IMPORTANT ORGANIZATIONAL
TASKS SUCH AS BOOKKEEPING CARING
FOR CHILDREN COOKING MEALS AND
KEEPING HOUSE IN OFTEN CRAMPED
MARTIN CONDITIONS. WOMEN'S WORK
WAS AT THE CORE OF WHAT THE
MOVEMENT WAS ABOUT DIGNITY AND
BETTER WORKING CONDITIONS THEY
ENDURED ALL THIS TO RESTORE
DIGNITY TO THE MEN AND WOMEN
DOING BACKBREAKING WORK WORK IN
THE FIELDS FOR LOW WAGES. AND
THE CHILDREN WHO HAD TO GO TO
SCHOOL WITH NO SHOES OR TO BED
WITH EMPTY STOMACHS. HELEN
CHAVEZ THE WIFE OF CESA CHAVEZ
WAS AMONG THOSE WOMEN WHO DID
THIS WORK. WE ALL KNOW DOLLARS
WEST I WAS IN ORGANIZED POWER
HOUSE- STRENGTH AND IN
LEADERSHIP IN ORGANIZING IS
UNPARALLELED OF COURSE WE'VE ALL
COME TO RESPECT AND ADMIRE YET
THERE WERE SO MANY FEMALE LABOR
LEADERS WHOSE NAME FEW OF US
KNOW LIKE LOUIS SOMEWHAT IN ALL.
MY DM MARTINEAU MADE CHEN HAD A
COUNTY AND AM I TEN I YOU'VE GOT
. SAYS THAT IS THAT ARE THE- IS
A NAME SO. WITH AN DURING YOU
JUST AND TRY. HE WAS AN EVERYDAY
MAN LED. TO FIGHT FOR DIGNITY
FOR THEMSELVES AND THEIR FAMILY.
LET US CELEBRATE HIM AND EVERY
OTHER EVERY DAY MAN MAN AND
WOMAN. WHOSE LIVES ARE FOREVER
CHANGED WHEN THEY FOUND THE
COURAGE TO RAISE THEIR VOICES. I
CHALLENGES ALL. TO TAKE ACTION
TO WORK FOR THE BETTERMENT OF
WORKERS AND FAMILIES WHO DREAM
OF A OF A BETTER LIFE. AND
DIGNITY IN WORK AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
TODAY. THANK YOU SENATE BRADFORD. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT I TO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SR
SEVENTY ONE ASSURE THE
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS WE
STAND HERE NOT ONLY RECOGNIZING
TODAY BUT THE INDIVIDUAL THAT I
OF SAYS R. D. CHAVEZ A NOT ONLY
A LABOR LEADER BUT A CIVIL
RIGHTS. LEADER A MAN OF SMALL
STATURE BUT A GIANT HEART AND-
INDEED. A MAN WHO WASN'T A GREAT
ORATOR OF MARTIN LUTHER KING.
BUT A MAN OF THE SLICE ACTION
WHO MOVED THIS. NATION FOR THE
BETTERMENT OF ALL PEOPLE CESAR
CHAVEZ HISTORY IN SERVICE AND
ADVOCACY IS FILLED WITH THE
INFLUENCE AND THE COOPERATION
WITH THE ARICAN AMERICAN
COMMUNITY EACH OF THE PRIOR
TEMPS TO ORGANIZE FARM WORKERS
UNIONS HAVE BEEN DESTROYED BY
RACISM AND CORPORATE POWER. BUT
SHAVIT SAYS. ALONG WITH OTHERS
THE LIBERTY CREATED A
MULTIRACIAL MOVEMENT A MEXICAN
AMERICANS FILIPINOS AFTER
AMERICANS DOMINICANS PORTER
RICANS IN ARAB WORKERS- JUST
AMONG FOOD FEUD TO FORM U. F. W.
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX MEMBERS OF
THE STUDENT. NONVIOLENT
COORDINATING COMMITTEE OR SNACK-
JOINED CESAR CHAVEZ AND THE
UNITED FARM WORKERS FOR TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY MILE MARCH FROM
DELANO. RIGHT HERE IN SACRAMENTO
ON THIS CAMP- CAPITAL TO PROTEST
EXPLOITATION. OF AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
SENT A TELEGRAM TO CESAR. CHAVEZ
IN NINETEEN SIXTY SIX. EARLY IN
AT FIVE YEAR DELAY GRAPE STRIKE
STRIKE I REMEMBER AS A KID.
LOVING GRAPES MY FATHER LOVED
GREAT MY MOTHER LOVE GREAT FOR
WE DIDN'T HAVE ANY GRAPES IN OUR
HOUSEHOLD FOR NUMBER YEARS
BECAUSE MY FATHER MOTHER WERE
ADAMANT ABOUT HONORING THE
FARMWORKERS IN THE STRIKE. OUR
SEPARATE STRUGGLES ARE REALLY
ONE DR KING OFTEN SAID THE
STRUGGLE OF FREEDOM AND FOR
DIGNITY AND FOR HUMANITY KING
SAID CROSSES ALL LINES WE ARE
TOGETHER WITH YOU IN SPIRIT AND
IN TERMINATION THAT OUR DREAMS
FOR A BETTER TOMORROW WILL BE
REALIZE. THE STUDENT NONVIOLENT
COORDINATING COMMITTEE WAS NOT
ONLY THE BLACK AND NOT ONLY
BLOCK ORGANIZATIONS SUPPORT U.
F. W. A LATER ON IN DOUBLE ACP
THE NATIONAL URBAN LEAGUE IN THE
SOUTHERN CHRISTIAN LEADERSHIP
CONFERENCE IN THE BLACK PANTHER
PARTY. BACKED THE FARMWORKERS
AND THEIR STRIKE AND BOYCOTTS
AGAINST CALIFORNIA AGRIBUSINESS
THROUGHOUT THE LATE SIXTIES AND
EARLY SEVENTIES. CESAR CHAVEZ
SAW PARALLELS IN THE WAY AFRICAN
AMERICANS RETREAT IN THE UNITED
STATES TO THE WAY THAT HE AND
HIS FELLOW MEXICAN AMERICANS
RETREATED HE ABSORBED MANY OF
THE TAXES TACTICS OF AFTER
AMERICAN CIVIL RIGHTS. ACTIVISTS
HAD EMPLOYED THROUGHOUT THE
SIXTIES APPLYING THEM TO HIS OWN
MOVEMENT. HE WAS WILLING TO TAKE
REST AND SACRIFICE HIS OWN
HEALTH AND LIFE FOR THE CALLS.
PROLONGED HUNGER STRIKES. TO
THIS DAY THE UNITED FARM WORKERS
CONTINUED THE TRADITION OF
COLLABORATING AND WORKING ALONG
WITH MANY OTHER LABOR AND RACIAL
JUSTICE ORGANIZATIONS I WAS
HONORED TO SPEND THIS PAST
FRIDAY WITH HIS GRANDSON. THESE
ARE L. SHELVES AND ON THE CITY
OF COMMUTE I'M S. CITY OF CARSON
CELEBRATING HIS LIFE AND HIS
WORK TOMORROW SHOULD NOT BE A
DAY OFF BUT A DAY ON. THE DAY OF
SERVICE IN THE MEMORY OF CESAR
CHAVEZ I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. GENERAL THIS HERTZBERG.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE I
RISE TODAY AS A MEMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE JEWISH
CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF SR SEVENTY
ONE THESE ARE TRAVESTY. HE ALONG
WITH SO MANY BRAVE INDIVIDUALS
CONTINUE TO BE A PIVOTAL PIECE
OF LABOR HISTORY. THE TIES
BETWEEN THE JEWISH COMMUNITY AND
LABOR ACTIVISM GO BACK MORE THAN
HALF A CENTURY BUT CONTINUE TO
GO STRONG. FROM JEWISH UNIONS TO
POLITICAL ACTIVISM THE RIGHTS OF
THE WORKER HAVE LONG BEEN OF
CONCERN TO THIS COMMUNITY. WHEN
THE NATIONAL FARM WORKERS
ASSOCIATION AND THE AGRICULTURAL
WORKERS ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE
TOOK TO STRIKE THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY SUPPORT AT THEM. RABBI
STICKLER THAT NONUNION GRAPES
VIOLATED THE RELIGIOUS TENANTS
NOT TO STEAL AN ACTIVIST JOIN
THE BECAUSE SOME EVEN LOSING
THEIR LIVES TO JOIN THE STRUGGLE
. NON FREEMEN A STUDENT JOINED
THE PACKERS IN SOLIDARITY AND
WAS KILLED BY A TRUCK PURPOSELY
DRIVING UNSAFELY BY THE PICKET
LINE. WHEN THE NATIONAL FARM
WORKERS ASSOCIATION AND THE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ORGANIZING
COMMITTEE MERGED THEY WERE
REPRESENTED BY JERRY CULLEN WHO
SAW THE FIGHT OF MISTER THOMAS
AS ONE OF ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE TODAY WE CARRY ON THAT
LEGACY. THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IS
PROUD TO REAFFIRM ITS SUPPORT
FOR THE LABOR MOVEMENT AND FOR
MR TRAVIS LEGACY. HONORING CESAR
CHAVEZ IS AN IMPORTANT PART OF
RECKONING WITH THE UNJUST
TREATMENT OF WORKERS ON A
PERSONAL NOTE MY FATHER CAME TO
THIS COUNTRY AS A FARM WORKER
THROUGH THAT BUT I FEDERAL
PROGRAM WE'RE THANKFUL FOR THE
WORK THE CESAR CHAVEZ DID ON
BEHALF OF WORKERS. IN JEWISH
TRADITION WE SAY. OF THE
DEPARTED MAY THEIR MEMORY BE
BLESSED WE SAY THIS IT AND
RECOGNITION. THAT IT IS OUR DUTY%
AS THOSE WHO CARRY THE DISEASE'S
MEMORY TO MAINTAIN THE
RIGHTEOUSNESS THEY BROUGHT INTO
THE WORLD. MAY CESAR CHAVEZ
MEMORY BE A BLESSING AND MAY WE
ALL CONTINUE THE WORK HE STARTED
I AM HONORED TO BE A AN AYE VOTE
ON SR SEVENTY ONE AND I URGE THE
SAME OF MY COLLEAGUES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU CENTER GROUP CENTER
HERTZBERG. MISTER PRESIDENT.
EACH OF US IN THIS CHAMBER. AT
THE HONOR OF SERVING THE PUBLIC
IN EXTRAORDINARY WAYS. THE
CONSEQUENCE OF OUR ROLES WE ALSO
OFTEN HAVE THE HONOR OF
EXPERIENCING AND MEETING
INTERESTING IMPORTANT PEOPLE. IN
BEING CIRCUMSTANCES THAT OTHERS
DON'T NECESSARILY GET TO BE IN.
I HAVE THAT HONORS YOUNG MAN AND
SOME OF YOU HAVE HEARD THIS. BUT
TO ME THAT'S A SHOT AS MANY
TIMES TO PARTICIPATE MANY WAS
MARCHES. LOOK IN THE EYE TALK TO
HIM TO LISTEN TO ONE. AND WE
OFTEN HAVE FOLKS THAT ARE ICONIC
IMPORTANT. THAT WE LEARN ABOUT
HISTORY. BUT MY EXPERIENCE IN
LISTENING TO HIM. WATCHING HIM
WISH TO SEE IN PERSON IN REAL
TIME LOOKING IS EYES SEEING
HOPING RELATED TO PEOPLE SEE HOW
HE DEALT WITH THE MOST
CONTROVERSIAL SITUATIONS WHAT
EXTRAORDINARY HUMAN TALENT HE
HAD. IT WAS JUST A GREAT LESSON
FOR SOMEONE LIKE ME. GREAT
INSPIRATION AND THE OTHER THING
I WOULD SHARE IS THAT FOR ALL OF
US WHO'VE BEEN IN PUBLIC LIFE
FOR MANY YEARS WE HAVE SEEN MANY
ORGANIZATIONS MANY GROUPS DO ALL
KINDS OF THINGS FROM SUCCESSFUL
AND NOT SUCCESSFUL. ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT I WATCHED HIM DO WAS
TO PUT TOGETHER A TEAM OF THE
MOST EXTRAORDINARY AND TALENTED
PEOPLE WHO NOT JUST HELP WITH
RESPECT TO THE FARMWORKERS BUT
WENT ON TO DO GREAT THINGS FOR
ADVICE JUNIOR FATHER CHILDREN AT
FEDERAL AS JUNIOR MARSHALL GANZ.
WITHIN CAMPAIGNS AND LEARN TO
THIS DAY S MANY OF THE THINGS I
LEARNED ABOUT HOW TO ORGANIZE A
MARCH AGAINST WENT OFF TO
HARVARD HE TEACH AT HARVARD
PATRICK DOWLING A DOCTOR WHO
WORKED WITH THE FARMWORKERS NOW
UCLA ATTENDING A FAMILY PRACTICE
RT RODRIGUEZ ARE TO REDUCE
PRESIDENT AFTER A SENSE OF
PASSED AWAY IN. NINETEEN NINETY
THREE A JUSTICE ORDINARY TALENTS
AND SO I WOULD JUST SUGGEST AS
WE HONOR WHAT HE DID I JUST
WANTED TO SHARE I THINK SOME
INSIGHTS CERTAINLY CENTER MONICA
WHO WORK FOR FIVE DOLLARS A WEEK
IS A LAWYER FIVE DOLLARS A WEEK
WOULDN'T PAY FOR THE NOODLES AND
HE HAD TO EAT. THAT'S WHAT
THAT'S WHAT THEY DID IN TERMS OF
FOLKS THAT- THAT BUILT AN
ORGANIZATION BASED UPON
COMMITMENT AND PEOPLE THAT WERE
EXTRAORDINARILY TALENTED THEY
DON'T THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE HONOR CENTER MINING IN
THAT REGARD AS WELL SO I WANT TO
STAND IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
RESOLUTION. AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING. ME THE TIME TO SHARE
SOME OF MY OBSERVATIONS. THANK
YOU INSTEAD OF THE MOST LIKE TO
CALL. THANK YOU. COLLEAGUES YOU
HAVE HER. THAT THIS. MAN THAT WE
ARE HONORING SAYS THAT A TRAVIS
IS MORE THAN THE PERSON IT IS
ABOUT THE MOVEMENT THE
CONVERSATION TODAY IN THE
COMMENTS- HAVE REFLECTED THE
MULTIRACIAL COMMUNITY THAT CAME
FORWARD TO SUPPORT. FARMWORKERS
AND TO SUPPORT THE CONDITIONS OF
WORKERS- YOU'VE ALSO HEARD SOME
OF THE STORIES. THAT RESONATE
DEEP WITH US ABOUT NOT HAVING
GRIEFS AT THE TABLE I SAW A LOT
OF FACES AND SMILES BECAUSE WE
ALL REMEMBER THAT MOMENT WHERE
WE MAYBE WANTED TO GREAT BUT
UNDERSTOOD THAT LACKED CAL SON
WAS ABOUT STANDING FOR THE
RIGHTS IT WAS ABOUT THE MOVEMENT
BEYOND THAT INDIVIDUAL MOMENT
WHEN YOU MAY WANT SOMETHING. I
AM GRATEFUL FOR THE SUPPORT AND
I HOPE THAT NOT JUST TODAY NOT
JUST IN THIS MOMENT BUT THAT WE
CAN HONOR HIS LEGACY AS WE THINK
OF THE ON GOING CONDITIONS THAT
SO MANY MARGINALIZED MEMBERS OF
OUR COMMUNITY EXPERIENCE. BUT WE
ALSO REMEMBER THE POTENTIAL THAT
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS
THE NATION WE HAVE THE ABILITY
TO CREATE MOVEMENTS THAT MATTER
TO OUR COMMUNITY MOVEMENTS THAT
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
EVERYONE WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
. THANK YOU SAN RAMON. THIS IS-
ELIGIBLE FREEDOMS ROLL CALL AT
THE INTERSECTIONS TO USING
RENOWNED UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. I
SEE NINETY AYE AYES ARE THIRTY
NINE THE NOSE REVERO RESOLUTION
PASSES. THANK YOU ARE MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING. ITEM
FILE ITEM FORTY FIVE CENTER
EGGMAN. MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE RELATIVE TO
TRANSPARENT GENDER DAY OF
VISIBILITY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS AT
TODAY I RISE ON BEHALF THE L. G.
B. T. Q. CAUCUS TO COMMEMORATE
TRANS DAY OF VISIBILITY. THERE
ARE OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE TRANS
GENDER NON CONFORMING OR
INTERSEX ALSO KNOWN AS TGI. DID
YOUR PEOPLE INTO JOB WOMEN OF
COLOR INCLUDING SYLVIA RIVERA
MISS MAJOR AND MARSHA P. JOHNSON
WHO WERE INSTRUMENTAL IN THE
CREATION OF THE MODERN DAY
RIGHTS. GAY RIGHTS MOVEMENT IN
THE UNITED STATES. AS A RESULT
OF THE DETERMINE ACTIVISM AND
ADVOCACY TGI PEOPLE NOW SERVE AS
COMMUNITY AND EDUCATIONAL
LEADERS. WITH ANDY MODERATE
BECOMING THE FIRST OPENLY
TRANSGENDER JUDGE APPOINTS THE
CALIFORNIA BENCH. JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO. FEDERAL DR RACHEL
LEVINE AS OUR ASSISTANT
SECRETARY OF HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES FOR THE FOUR. FOUR AT
COUNT FOR THE UNITED STATES.
CIVIL RIGHTS VICTORIES WON BY
THESE ACTIVISTS HAVE EXPANDED
JUDICIAL RECOGNITION OF
CONSTITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS AND
WE'VE JUST BEGUN TO TEAR DOWN
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS THAT HAVE
RESULTED FROM THE MANY YEARS. OF
TRAGIC EXCLUSION. BUT THROUGHOUT
THE COUNTRY. THESE TRANS RIGHTS
ARE UNDER TAX THROUGH TARGETED
ANTI TRANS LEGISLATIONS WE SEE
IN STATES ACROSS STATES ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY CULTURAL WARS
HEATING UP AND OUR KIDS AT THE
CENTER OF THAT OPPRESSION. IN
LIGHT OF THAT RECOGNITION IN
CALIFORNIA THE TRANSLATE FOR THE
FIRST TIME EVER WILL FLY ABOVE
OUR STATE CAPITOL TO BACK INTO
ALL IN THE IN THE STATE AND
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT WE SEE
YOU WE RECOGNIZE YOU YOUR
ACCEPTED. AND LOVED WE AFFIRM
THAT WE BELIEVE IN THE HER AND
VALUE OF EACH AND EVERY RESIDENT
OF CALIFORNIA WE JUST REFLECTED
ON THE WORK OF SIX ARE CHÁVEZ
AND WE KNOW A CORE FOR HIM WAS
TO STAND UP EARLY FOR THE LGBTQ
COMMUNITY WAY BEFORE ANYBODY
ELSE DID. ATTENDED THE SECOND
EVER MARCH AND UNDERSTOOD MORE
THAN ANYBODY ELSE THAT WE CAN
ONLY ACHIEVE THROUGH EQUITY AND
ACCEPTANCE THROUGH UNITY- I ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. ON S. C. A.
C. R. ONE SIXTY ONE. THANK YOU
ANY DISCUSSION DEBATE AMERIPRISE
AMERICANS. THANK YOU SO MUCH
MISTER PRESIDENT I FEEL
COLLEAGUES COMPELLED TO RISE
TODAY IN SUPPORT OF NOT JUST A
RESOLUTION BUT IN SUPPORT OF
TRANSGENDER INDIVIDUALS
THROUGHOUT OUR COMMUNITIES OUR
STATE AND OUR COUNTRY IT'S
STAGGERING AND DISHEARTENING
THAT FOR ALL THE GAINS WE'VE
MADE OVER THE YEARS THERE ARE
STEPS BEING TAKEN TO A ROAD OUR
RIGHTS TO MAKE PEOPLE FEEL
INVISIBLE TO DENY PEOPLE THEIR
ABILITY TO LIVE AUTHENTICALLY.
TRANSFERABLE ESPECIALLY BLACK
AND LET NEXT TRANS PEOPLE
CONTINUE TO BE KILLED ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY AND HORRIFYING
NUMBERS. AND A NUMBER OF STATES
WERE SEEN BLATANT AWFUL ATTACKS
BEING WAGED AGAINST OUR LGBTQ
SIBLINGS IN YOUTH. PARENTS WHO
LOVE AND SUPPORT THEIR TRANS
CHILDREN UNCONDITIONALLY ARE
BEING ACCUSED OF CHILD ABUSE.
AND IN NEARLY A DOZEN STATES
TRANS ATHLETES ARE BEING BANNED
FROM SPORTS THAT ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THEIR GENDER IDENTITY. THIS
WON'T BE ALLOWED TO HAPPEN AND
WE WON'T LET THIS GO ON
ANSWERED. NOT ON OUR WATCH AND
NOT IN OUR STATE. VITRIOL AND
VICIOUS ATTACKS WON'T BE
TOLERATED IN CALIFORNIA. AND TO
MY TRANS SIBLINGS I SAY. AS ARE.
MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON SAID
YOU WERE SEEN YOU ARE RESPECTED
AND YOU WILL ALWAYS BE WELCOME
HERE. AND WHO ARE TRANS YOUTH I
SAY YOU ARE BRAVE YOUR LOVED AND
YOU ARE WORTH FIGHTING FOR.
SENATORS I'M PROUD THAT WERE
TAKEN THE STEP TODAY IN ADOPTING
ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
ONE SIXTY ONE AND I APPLAUD OUR
ASSEMBLY CALLING FROM SAN JOSE
FOR LEADING THIS EFFORT. WE MUST
CONTINUE TO TAKE ACTION THAT
WILL MAKE LIFE BETTER FOR
EVERYONE LESBIAN GAY BISEXUAL
TRANSGENDER INTERSEX PANSEXUAL
NON BINARY GENDER NONCONFORMING.
ALL QUEER PEOPLE. LOOK MANY OF
US MAY NOT UNDERSTAND MY OWN
PARENTS DIDN'T UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHEN I CAME OUT. BUT THE
GREATEST GIFT THAT THEY GAVE TO
ME WAS ALWAYS UNCONDITIONAL LOVE
AND SUPPORT. MY MOTHER WAS A
GOOD WOMAN OF FAITH AND SHE
BELIEVED SINCERELY IN NOT
JUDGING OTHERS AND THAT ALLOWED
HER TO LOVE AND TO BE THE BEST
MOM. TO ME AND MY SIBLINGS. THE
COLLEAGUES WITH THAT%
UNDERSTANDING IN MY LIFE IN MY
HEART I URGE YOU TO STEP OUT OF
YOUR COMFORT ZONE AND TRY TO
UNDERSTAND A LITTLE MORE. AND TO
SUPPORT ACR ONE SIXTY ONE. THANK
YOU MAYOR PRO TEM CENTER WIENER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- MISTER
PRESIDENT AND I ALSO JUST WANT
TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM. FROM
STOCKTON AND ALSO MADAM PER TIME
AFTER THERE ARE BEAUTIFUL
REMARKS- SHOWING ONCE AGAIN
THAT- WE LOVE OUR ALLIES BUT
HAVING. A SEAT AT THE TABLE-
MATTERS MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE
IN THE WORLD- I RISE TODAY BOTH
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE JEWISH
CAUCUS AND ALSO AS A GAY MAN IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ON ONE SIXTY ONE-
YOU KNOW KOHLI SAID AYE AYE WITH
ALL THE CULTURE WARS. THAT ARE
HAPPENING TODAY AND IT'S REALLY
I JUST HAVE TO SAY. THAT THE
IDEA THAT ELECTED OFFICIALS IN
THIS COUNTRY ARE TRYING TO SCORE
POLITICAL POINTS. POSITION
THEMSELVES TO RUN FOR PRESIDENT
. OR WHATEVER THE CASE MAY BE
SCORING POLITICAL POINTS THAN
ADVANCING THEIR OWN POLITICAL
CAREERS ON THE BACKS OF CHILDREN
. I MEAN LITERALLY AND WE SAW
THIS IN THE- RECENT SUPREME
COURT HEARINGS WHERE YOU HAD US
SENATORS WHO WERE OUT WHO ALL
WANT TO BE PRESIDENT. WHO WERE
SCRAMBLING AT THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO ATTACK TRANSFERABLE. TO THE
ATTACK LEAH THOMAS. UNITED TRANS
WOMAN WHO ACTUALLY ONE. A
SWIMMING CHAMPIONSHIP AND
INSTEAD OF BEING CELEBRATED FOR
HER ATHLETIC PROWESS. WAS
COMPLETELY SAVAGED CAN YOU
IMAGINE YOU'RE A YOUNG PERSON
YOU YOU YOU ACHIEVE THIS GOAL
AND YOU'RE ATTACKING TOLD THE
YOU'RE A SCAM ARTIST. AND A
FRAUD. NO ONE TALKS ABOUT ALL OF
THE- TIMES WHEN AS A CISGENDER
WOMAN DEFEATS A TRANS WOMAN IN
AN IN A SPORTS COMPETITION THAT
HAPPENS A LOT. WITH THE SYSTEM
THE WOMAN WINS
TRANSCONTINENTAL'S KNOWN TALKS
ABOUT THAT BUT GOD FOR BID A
TRANS WOMAN ACTUALLY WINS
SOMETIMES. IT'S NOT AN ACTUAL
VICTORY IT'S NOW A SCAM OR A
FRAUD. AND WE SEE POLITICIANS
WHO ARE. POURING FUEL ON THAT
FIRE. AND IT'S JUST IT'S JUST
DESPICABLE. AND THEN WE SEE
THESE TRENDS KIDS WHOSE.
UNIVERSE SO MANY TRANS KIDS AN
LGBTQ KIDS WHO WERE REJECTED BY
THEIR FAMILIES AND THAT'S WHY
THE RATES OF SUICIDE AMONG LGBT
KIDS IS SO HIGH. THAT'S WHY I'M
ABOUT HALF ABOUT HALF OF
HOMELESS YOUTH IDENTIFY AS LGBTQ
50% THREE TWO TWO Q. ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM. THIS ISN'T A RANDOM.
IT'S BECAUSE OF REJECTION OFTEN
BY THE FAMILY. AND SO IMAGINE
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE A FAMILY YOU
ACTUALLY EMBRACES THEIR TRANS
CHILD AND SUPPORTS THAT CHILD
AND LOVES THAT CHILD. AND MAKE
SURE THAT CHILD HAS ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE WE NOW HAVE STATES
SAYING YOU'RE A CRIMINAL. WE'RE
GONNA PUT THE PARENT AND
IMPRISONED IN IDAHO THEY WERE
PROPOSING LIFE IN PRISON FOR A
PARENT WHO ALLOWS OUR TRANSCRIPT
HAVE HEALTH CARE. AND WE'RE
GONNA TAKE THE KID ON PUT THE
CAN IN FOSTER CARE. HE MAGIC IF
YOU'RE A CHILD MANAGING OF ANY
OF US. WHEN WE WERE SIX OR EIGHT
OR TEN OR TWELVE YEARS OLD I GOT
A SIGNAL BECAUSE OF WHO YOU ARE.
YOUR PARENTS ARE GOING TO PRISON
AND YOU'RE GOING ON THE FOSTER
CARE. THAT'S A SIGNAL THE
POLITICIANS IN THIS COUNTRY. ARE
SENDING TO THESE CHILDREN.
BERMAN TOLD THAT THEY ARE SCAM
ARTISTS THAT ARE FAKE BUT THEY
DON'T REALLY EXIST. BUT THERE'S
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THEM. AND
THEN PEOPLE WONDER WHY SO MANY
TRY TO SELF HARM. YOU KNOW THIS
THIS IS ALSO TRANS TRANSGENDER
PEOPLE ARE NOT NEW. TRANSFERABLE
ALWAYS EXISTED IN SOCIETY WE
KNOW THAT A NATIVE AMERICAN
TRADITIONS. TRANSGENDER PEOPLE
WORK CELEBRATED HAD A SPECIAL
CHERISHED STATUS FOREVER. ROBERT
IN IN SOME JEWISH LEGAL
TRADITIONS FROM CENTURIES AND
CENTURIES AND MILLENNIA AGO.
THERE ARE SIX GENDERS THERE'S A
RECOGNITION THE NOT THAT THAT'S
NOT A PURE BINARY THE DOES THERE
THERE ARE THERE IS A SPECTRUM.
AND SO THIS IS NOT NEW. BUT WHAT
IS NEW. ARE THE ATTACKS AND THE
DEMONISATION AND THE DISTORTION
OF RELIGION TO JUSTIFY THOSE
ATTACKS ON OUR TRANSIT LINES AND
PARTICULAR TRANS CHILDREN- TIME
TALKED ABOUT THE EPIDEMIC OF
VIOLENCE AGAINST TRANS PEOPLE IN
PARTICULAR TRANS WOMEN OF COLOR
WHO ARE BEING MURDERED ACROSS
THIS COUNTRY. WE BECAUSE WE HAVE
TO RESET HOW THE HELL WE TALK
ABOUT TRANS PEOPLE IT'S NOT OKAY
THE DEMONISATION THAT'S
HAPPENING AND ON THIS TRANS
THEIR VISIBILITY WE NEED TO
RECONNECT TO SUPPORT. OF THIS
COMMUNITY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER PATTERSON CENTER SKINNER
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT-
CENTERS I TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR ONE SIXTY ONE IN THE SPHERE
OF THE ASIAN PACIFIC ISLANDER-
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- MOTORIZED IN
SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SIXTY ONE
RECOGNIZES TRANSGENDER DAY OF
VISIBILITY AND PAID FOR THAT-
THE AUTHOR OF THIS RESOLUTION
ASSEMBLY IS A MEMBER OF OUR
CAUCUS. YOU KNOW THE- THIS
RESOLUTION ACOSTA RAISING
AWARENESS OF THE MANY HARDSHIPS
AND SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTIONS OF
TRANS GENDER NON CONFORMING OR
INTERSEX COMMUNITIES.
UNFORTUNATELY BECAUSE CULTURE
RELIGIOUS DIFFERENCES THERE ARE
SOME EVEN WITHIN THE API
COMMUNITY WHO STILL EXPRESS A
LOT OF UNCERTAINTY AND FEAR
TOWARDS. THE TGI COMMUNITY.
HOWEVER RESOLUTIONS LIKE THIS
ONE EIGHT ZERO ONE SIXTY ONE
HELPS BRIDGE THE CONVERSATIONS
THE LETTERS IN THE- ASIAN
AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER TGI
COMMUNITY KNOW THAT THEY'RE NOT
ALONE. VISIBILITY WHICH IS
SOMETHING OUR COMMUNITY HAS
CONSTANTLY TALKED ABOUT OUR LACK
OF VISIBILITY VISIBILITY IS THE
FIRST STEP. IN ADVANCING THE
NEEDS OF THE COMMUNITY THAT
INCLUDES. OUR FLY TGI COMMITTEE
TRANSGENDER COMMUNITY. HOWEVER
ACTIONS MUST BE TAKEN TO ENSURE
SYSTEMIC BARRIERS ARE REMOVED IN
A HUMAN RIGHTS ARE UPHELD FOR
ALL. I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT
AN ASIAN AMERICAN- SCOTT CHUNG
WHO TOOK ACTION WAS AT THE
CENTER OF PASSING THE LANDMARK
RESPECT AFTER DEATH ACT. WHICH
ALLOW TRANSGENDER PEOPLE TO
RECORD THE CHOSEN GENDER ON
THEIR DEATH CERTIFICATES. AFTER
CHINESE AMERICAN CHRISTOPHER LEE
A TRANSGENDER MALE COMMITTED
SUICIDE HIS DEATH CERTIFICATE.
LISTED THIS MAN IS A FEMALE.
SCOTT CHARM WAS A FRIEND OF MR
LEE'S AND ALSO IDENTIFIES AS
TRANSGENDER MAN BROUGHT THE
DEATH CERTIFICATE TO DETENTION A
TRANSGENDER LAW CENTER. AS A
RESULT OF MR TRANSACTION THE
TRANSGENDER LAW CENTER AND
INITIATE THE INTRODUCTION
EVENTUAL PASSAGE OF THE RESPECT
AFTER DEATH ACT. LETS US LEARN
FROM THEIR EXAMPLE REMEMBER TAKE
ACTIONS ENSURED THAT EVERYONE'S
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS ARE UPHELD. I
WOULD ALSO JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY
TAKE NOTES- AS NOT NOT AS CHAIR
OF THE API LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS
BUT AS A- PEDIATRICIAN- REPORTS
OF THIS ISSUE AND- I WAS
PARTICULARLY TOUCHED BY V. I. C.
T. V. TELL MESSAGE OF THE
GOVERNOR OF IDAHO. SO THE
LEGISLATURE IDAHO- PASSED A LAW-
BASICALLY BANNING. TRANSGENDER-
THEN FROM SPORTS AND IN HIS VETO
MESSAGE HE MADE NOTE THAT. IN
THE STATE OF IDAHO DOOR SEVENTY
FIVE THOUSAND CHILDREN IN SCHOOL
- THERE WAS ONE TRANSGENDER GIRL. THE SPORTS IN IDAHO HE SAID
BURKE THIS. YOU KNOW WE ARE
DOING THIS LAW BECAUSE ONE GIRL
. AT THE CLOSE OF FRIENDS. THE
STOCK COMPASSION. BUT THAT I ASK
FOR I THINK IT. THANK YOU CENTER
PENN CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU
MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE AS
IN SUPPORT OF ACR ONE SIXTY ONE
AS VICE CHAIR OF THE WOMEN'S
CAUCUS. I'M AND I REALLY FOR THE
VERY L. COMMENT BY A COLLEAGUE
SO FAR ON THE RESOLUTION- WE ARE
IN THIS FACE THE CITY OF MORE
AND MORE STATE. PASSING LAWS IN
PAUL. TO HURT WE CAN SAY
DISCRIMINATE BUT TO HURT AND
HARM TRANSGENDER PEOPLE AND AT
THE SAME TIME. WE HAD A VERY
INTERESTING NATIONAL. OF THOSE
OF YOU WHO ARE FANS OF JEOPARDY
I HAPPEN TO BE ONE YOU MAY HAVE
NOTICED THAT MY CONSTITUENT AB
SCHNEIDER WHO HAD THE SECOND
LONGEST WINNING STREAK IN
JEOPARDY HISTORY HE STARTED TO
RUN LAST FALL. AND I KEPT IT
GOING WINNING OVER ONE POINT
FOUR MILLION DOLLARS UNTIL I
THINK IT WAS- NOVEMBER. OPENLY
TRANSFERS NOW THE JEOPARDY HOST
NEVER INTRODUCED AMY AS A TRANS
NOR DID AMY STATE IT EXPLICITLY
WHILE HE WAS THE CONTESTANT
THOUGH SHE DID NOT HIDE IT WHAT
SO EVER. EIGHTY NINE AMY HAD A
VERY VERY ACTIVE TWITTER ACCOUNT
STILL DOES. AND SHE WOULD
RECOUNT HER IN STRATEGIES FOR
WINNING THAT GAME BUT ALSO HER
PERSONAL LIFE. IN IN THAT
PROCESS ANYONE WHO FOLLOWED HER
TWITTER ACCOUNT SORRY. PEOPLE I
MEAN IT WAS AMAZING THERE WAS-
ONE OF THE PEOPLE INTERACTING ON
HER TWITTER ACCOUNT DESCRIBES
HOW HE WATCHED JEOPARDY WITH HIS
GRANDFATHER AND HIS GRANDFATHER
WAS AT INFIRM BUT HIS
GRANDFATHER HAD ALWAYS BEEN VERY
PREJUDICED. TOWARDS ALL LGBTQ
PEOPLE AND THIS REALLY HURTS THE
YOUNG MAN WHO WOULD WATCH
JEOPARDY WITH HIS GRANDFATHER.
BUT AS HIS GRANDFATHER OBSERVED
AMY SCHNEIDER AND WOULD TALK TO
HIS GRANDSON ABOUT. HE CONCLUDED
THAT WELL YOU KNOW. MAYBE IT'S
NOT SO. ODD OR MAYBE I MAYBE
IT'S REALLY OKAY THIS WEEK
COMPLETELY THE GRANDFATHER
COMPLETELY CHANGED HIS MIND AND
OPENED HIS HEART TO TRANSCEND
LGBTQ PEOPLE FROM WATCHING
JEOPARDY. AB SCHNEIDER HERSELF
TALKED ABOUT THAT REALLY THE
BIGGEST IMPACT OF HER EING ON
JEOPARDY WAS CREATING THAT
VISIBILITY AND NOT AWARENESS AND
ACCEPTANCE FOR TRANS PEOPLE. SO
I'M VERY VERY GLAD THAT OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM THE ASSEMBLY HAS
BROUGHT FORWARD THIS RESOLUTION.
I LOOK FORWARD TO MORE AND MORE
TRANS PEOPLE BEING IN VERY.
PROMINENT IN PUBLIC POSITIONS SO
THAT WE CAN ALL GET TO THE PLACE
OF COMFORT. AND ACCEPTANCE AND
SUPPORT WITH THAT I ASK THE
ARRIVAL. THANK YOU CENTER EGGMAN
WOULD GO TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I THINK MY COLLEAGUES
WHO SPOKE SO ELOQUENTLY AND- AND
WITH THE MOTION ON THE SUBJECT
BECAUSE IT IS EMOTIONAL FOR
PEOPLE IT IS ABOUT WHO PEOPLE
ARE AND HOW PEOPLE IDENTIFY IN
IN IN WHAT WE MANY OF US OBSERVE
WITH WITH HORROR AND- FEAR AND-
DISBELIEF THAT OUR COUNTRY SEEMS
TO BE GOING BACKWARDS ON THIS
ISSUE RATHER THAN FORWARDS AND
PEOPLE SEEM TO BE TAKING THE
LEAD IN- ENJOY. IN IN TEARING
PEOPLE DOWN AND MAKING PEOPLE
FEEL DIFFERENT AND I JUST LIKE
TO MAKE THE POINT AS WE KNOW
THAT THIS TWO THOUSAND TWENTY
ONE IT WAS THE DEADLIEST YEAR ON
RECORD FOR TGI PEOPLE. AND THIS
VILE HOMOPHOBIC TRANSPHOBIC.
FEVER THAT IS SWEEPING ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY. I'M IN MY OWN
FAMILY IN. IT DIDN'T IT WOULD IN
NEVADA A YOUNG COUSIN. RILEY
INCREDIBLY TALENTED AN ARTIST A
SINGER A PIANO PLAYER INCREDIBLY
TALENTED WHO IDENTIFIED AS
TRANSGENDER WHO WANTED TO
TRANSITION. PARENTS REFUSED AND
PARTLY MEMBERS ARE GONNA THINK
ABOUT THIS RIGHT I MEAN AS AS
OUR PRO TEM ELOQUENTLY SPOKE OUR
PARENTS ARE ALWAYS WORRIED ABOUT
US I REMEMBER WHEN I CAME OUT
WHEN PARENTS BIGGEST FEAR WAS
ARE YOU GOING TO BE OKAY. I
REMEMBER SPEAKING ON THE
RESOLUTION FOUR- POST THE POST
MURDER THAT HAPPENED IN IN- IN
MIAMI A COUPLE YEARS AGO EVERY
PARENT THINKS IS MY CHILD GOING
TO BE OKAY AND TO THINK ABOUT
WHEN YOU HEAR ALL THESE STORIES
ACROSS THE COUNTRY YOU KNOW IF
YOU ARE A PARENT OF A
TRANSPARENT ALL MY GOD IF ONLY I
CAN. HOW CAN I KEEP MY CHILD
SAFE AND FOR SOME PEOPLE THAT IS
ASKING YOUR CHILD NOT TO BE WHO
THEY ARE. MY FAMILY MEMBERS
HOLDER TOLD THE COULD NOT BE WHO
THEY WERE THEY WOULD NOT SUPPORT
IT. UNDER THEIR ROOF. WHEN RILEY
TURNED EIGHTEEN RILEY SAID I'M
GOING TO CONTINUE THIS. ON MY
OWN. INSTEAD THEN PLEASE LEAVE.
THE DAY BEFORE CHRISTMAS. THE
DAY AFTER CHRISTMAS LAST YEAR.
RALLY ACCIDENTALLY OVERDOSED.
PARENTS NOW LIVE WITH THAT.
FOREVER AS DOES THE REST OF MY
FAMILY AND BECAUSE WE KNOW THIS
HAPPENS EVERY SINGLE DAY. YOUNG
PEOPLE NOT FEELING ACCEPTED NOT
FEELING VALUED FOR WHO THEY ARE.
OUR COUNTRY IS TAKING A STEP
BACKWARDS FRIENDS. LET US ALL
TOMORROW AS WE GO FORWARD AND
THINK ABOUT CESAR CHAVEZ. IN HIS
SERVICE IN THE UNITY AND MAYBE
WE'RE GONNA FASTER GOING TO DO
DIFFERENT THINGS AS WE THINK
ABOUT HIS WORDS AND WE THINK
ABOUT THE COURAGE OF OUR
COUNTRY. THE COURAGE OF ALL OF
US TO SAY THIS IS NOT OKAY.
CULTURAL WARS THAT ARE RIPPING
US APART OR NOT OKAY WE CAN ONLY
GET TO UNITY AND EQUITY IF WE DO
IT TOGETHER AND LET US SAY IN
OUR HEARTS. WHETHER I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. ON ACR. ONE SIXTY
ONE. THANK YOU FOR THAT POWERFUL
CLOSE BETTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
FIVE ATKINS AYE BATES. BAKER I
FOR JUST. BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTESE AYE DALY. DODD AYE ZERO
AYE EGGMAN AYE GLAZER AYE
GONZALEZ I GROWTH. HERTZBERG I
WESTERN. I HER TADO I JONES.
KAMLAGER I LAYERED I LEYVA I
LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE AYE MELENDEZ.
MANY AYE NEWMAN AYE NIELSEN. BUT
TROUBLED PAN AYE PORTANTINO I
ROTH AYE RUBIO I SKINNER I STERN
I AM BURKE I WOULD CASTING AYE
WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN I AS FORTUS
DALLY GROVE JONES MELENDEZ
NIELSEN BUT CHOI BOGUE WELL.
HISER THIRTY ONE THE NEW ZERO
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES. MEMBERS
MOVING ONTO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ARE THERE ANY MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. S. C. NINE MM
SECRETARY CAN YOU READ PLEASE
READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATE BILL TEN EIGHTY. THANK
YOU KNOW BOB CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON FILE IN FORTY SEVEN
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES. I BAKER HI HI FOR JUST
AYE BRADFORD AYE CABRERA AYE
CORTESE AYE DALLY AYE DODD. I
TORONTO I EGGMAN AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. I GROWTH. I HERTZBERG
AYE WESTERN. I HER TADO I JONES
I KAMLAGER I LAYERED AYE LEYVA
AYE LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE. I
MELENDEZ FIVE MILLION. NEWMAN I
NIELSEN I A CHIRLA BOTH. HI PAN
AYE PORTANTINO AYE ROTH I RUBIO
. I SKINNER AYE STERN I NUMBER
FIVE BY CAL SKI. WIENER AYE WILK. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
. GLAZER AYE MIN. WHITE HOUSE
SKI I WELL.
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS FORMER TIME MAN I. WELL. THIRTY NINE THIRTY ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS APPROVED BY
NOW MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER CAREER TO
THE COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENT. YES
I DO MISTER PRESIDENT OF THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
WILL MEET THIRTY MINUTES AFTER
THE ADJOURNMENT OF SESSION IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED AT THE-
STREET BUILDING. THANK YOU IN
CENTER RUBIO. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AT THE ENTRANCE
COMMITTEE WILL MEET HERE A HALF
HOUR. AFTER SESSION CONCLUDES
AND I JUST WANT TO ENCOURAGE ALL
MEMBERS TO PLEASE SHOW UP WE
HAVE ONE BILL IT'S GOING TO GO
REALLY QUICKLY AND WE ALL NEED
TO GET OUT OF HERE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RETURNING TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS THIS IS A TIME
FOR A JOURNEY MEMORY. BY SEVEN
TO PLEASE KINDLY TAKE YOUR SEATS
. AND TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS
OFF THE FLOOR. WHEN I RECOGNIZE
CENTER DOLLY. THANK YOU. MR
PRESIDENT MEMBERS I RISE WITH
THE THAT THE DEPARTMENT A
JOURNEY MEMORY OF KATHY LYNCH.
WHO IS AN ADVOCATE WITH
INTEGRITY AND RESPECT AND LOVE
BY MANY TRAGICALLY KATHY WAS
TAKEN FROM US TOO SOON. KATHY
STARTED HER LOBBYING FIRM LYNCH
AND ASSOCIATES IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY FIVE. HIS LETS CLIENTS
INCLUDED BUSINESS AND TRADE
ASSOCIATIONS THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR AND EDUCATION INTEREST IN
CALIFORNIA. PRIOR TO ENDING THE
WORLD A PUBLIC POLICY MISS LYNCH
WORKED FOR NEW YORK BASED
FORTUNE FIVE HUNDRED COMPANY
WHERE SHE SPECIALIZED IN LABOR
RELATIONS AND ADMINISTRATION. HE
EARNED HER BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE
DEGREE IN NURSING FROM MOUNT
MERCY COLLEGE AND HER MASTER'S
OF SCIENCE DEGREE IN LABOR AND
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS FROM IOWA
STATE UNIVERSITY. SHOWING HER
COMPASSION FOR OTHERS KATHY
WOULD EVEN PRACTICE AS HE
CORONARY CARE NURSE AT LOCAL
HOSPITALS ON OCCASION DURING THE
WEEKENDS. KATHY HAD AN
UNWAVERING COMMITMENT TO
ADVOCATING FOR LEGISLATION AT
THE STATE CAPITOL AND WAS
INVOLVED INVOLVED IN MANY
PROFESSIONAL AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. HE CARE DEEPLY
ABOUT THE WORK THAT GOES ON IN
THIS BUILDING. AND WITH THE X.
M. WAS EXPRESSLY PASSIONATE
BEING THE BEST ADVOCATE FOR
CLIENTS BECAUSE SHE BELIEVED IN
THE MISSIONS AND THEIR ISSUES.
IT IS OUR HOPE AND PRAYER THAT
THOSE WHO WORKED AROUND KATHY
RESPECT HER FOR HER COMMITMENT
TO DOING EVERYTHING SHE COULD.
TO HELP MAKE CALIFORNIA A BETTER
PLACE. I ASKED WE ADJOURN IN HER
MEMORY TODAY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER DOLLARS CENTER
NIELSEN. THIS PRESIDENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN THE SENATE. I DO
NOT AS WELL RISE WITH A HEAVY
HEART. KNOWN KATHY FOR SOME YOUR
FORTY YEARS. AS A STRONG
ADVOCATE STANDING FOURTH FOR
WHAT SHE BELIEVED IN. FOR HOME
AND FOR THE ISSUES. HE ADVOCATED
FOR. GIVE ALL OF OUR HEART TO IT
. SHE HAVE A CATERED IN AREAS OF
SOME CONTROVERSY. THE RIGHT TO
KEEP AND BEAR ARMS. THERE WERE
OTHER CLIENTS AS WELL BUT- AS
YOU KNOW THAT'S SOMEWHAT
CONTROVERSIAL AROUND HER HERE.
KATHY NEVER BLINKED TONIGHT SHE
KNEW WHAT SHE BELIEVED IN. AND
SHE DID HAVE A ADVOCACY FIRM.
FOR HER. THAT WAS VERY SECONDARY
TO OUR FUNDAMENTAL FIRST
AMENDMENT POLICE. SHE WAS ALWAYS
GRACIOUS NOT COMBAT EVAN
CONFRONTING FOR. FRIENDLY THE
SOLID CITIZEN. A GOOD EXAMPLE
WHAT ADVOCACY CAN BE AROUND HERE
. AND IS AND ALWAYS. HER PARTNER
IN LIFE JERRY APPLE ALSO. WAS A
SUPERB ADVOCATE. EXITING THE
SAME QUALITIES. THEY ENJOYED A
GOOD PARTNERSHIP. THOSE OF US
WHO KNEW THEM. WE'RE SHOCKED.
AND THERE ARE OCCASIONS WHEN
SUCH NEWS. REALLY DOES SET YOU
BACK. THIS ONE SETBACK. THERE
SEEMS TO BE SOME INJUSTICE. WHEN
YOU LOSE SOMEONE UNDER THE
CIRCUMSTANCES THAT SHE PASSED.
EXTRA TRAGIC. BUT WE KNOW THAT
SHE IS IN GOD'S HANDS. DOES WILL
BE DONE. THEN WITH MY WIFE AND I
CONTINUE TO FERVENTLY PRAY FOR
KATHY. AND JERRY UP ALL. THANK
YOU FOR THE SENATE THE JOURNEY
IN THEIR HONOR TODAY. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN ACERTAR PLEASE
BRING AN ENFORCER SHOULD
PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED. MEMBERS
OF THE SHOW THE BUSINESS CENTER
BASICALLY DESK IT'S CLEAR. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
AT WHICH TIME THEY ADJOURNMENT
MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE WILL
RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM TO
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND. THANK YOU.
WE RECONVENE MONDAY AT TWO PM
THANK YOU MEMBERS.